Keith Urban has the best night ever
all right the winner is Oh Keith Irvin
again the 49 year old country crooner
took home four honors at Wednesday's CMT
Music Awards including video of the year
for his single blue ain't your color
[Applause]
urban used his acceptance speech to
thank fans for connecting with his music
I love making music I love making videos
I love making records I love writing
songs I love touring I love what I get
to do maybe more than ever right now
because who knows how long you get to do
it as for the sexy Aussies other three
Awards he won collaborative video of the
year for his song fighter with Carrie
Underwood the social superstar award and
male video of the year once again for
blue ain't your color this trophy he
dedicated to his leading lady Nicole
Kidman I want to say a massive thank you
to my wife Nicole Mary because you have
no idea how much of what I do she's
involved in every little piece of that
she helps me so much make these videos
what they are can we say hashtags swoon
before the show the two lovebirds hit
the red carpet where they exchanged
adoring gazes and lots of cuddles
[Music]
you